a lot of times right when we sit down
the four of us will sit down for dinner
you'll say to me oh no politics tonight
or something like that
so i started this and all of a sudden
i'm in vietnam
and then without without question you're
the one who brings up politics but oh
yeah but oh yeah but but i always say to
you the same thing and i i mean it which
is if we never talked politics there's a
million other things for us to talk
about which we always find we find them
anyway
amphibians cereal what's your
hollywood celebrities colleagues and
fans reeling from
bob saget's shocking death at 65 years
old including our next guest a close
friend of saggetts and his guest on that
podcast here with more on the
devastating loss reuben report host dave
rubin good morning to you dave
hey good morning guys
good morning i'm so sorry for the loss
of your friend tell us about him and how
you all met
yeah you know bob really was a great guy
and that clip kind of summed up our
relationship you know everyone knows
danny tanner from full house and
everybody remembers bob from america's
funniest home videos
but the bob that i knew he just it
wasn't that he just wanted to make
people laugh he wanted everybody to be
happy i mean we we would argue about
politics because basically i was trying
to get him to maybe come a little more
to my side he was sometimes trying to
get me to come along to his side but it
was really that he just wanted everybody
to be happy we met
uh i was doing stand-up a couple years
ago and his wife kelly was in the
audience bob was in the other room at
the comedy store and she said hey you
might know my uh my boyfriend bob saget
we should we should all get dinner and
we fast became friends i was actually on
tour in europe uh for their wedding and
i i flew all the way across the world
just for one day back in cali to go to
their wedding and they were he was just
a great guy you know we lost
betty white of course a couple weeks ago
who was sort of like america's
grandmother and bob was sort of like
america's dad and we don't have too many
people in hollywood these days who kind
of bring everybody together and i hope
that that's what bob's legacy will be
that's what i'll try to do with it
you know uh david it would seem like he
had an effect on a lot of people uh in
and out of comedy one is pete davidson
an up up-and-coming
star at snl
i was shocked to see this the depth of
his involvement helping him out because
he had some well publicized and he talks
about it he says he has borderline
he has borderline personality and he
said this when i was younger and several
times throughout our friendship he
helped me get through some rough mental
health stuff he stayed on the phone with
my mom for hours trying to help in any
way he can connecting us with doctors
and new things we can try he would check
in on me and make sure i was okay that's
fascinating that's a guy 20 years
younger than him too
yeah and it doesn't surprise me i
actually didn't know that they had a
relationship or that bob was helping him
specifically but that was the way bob
was i know bob helped an awful lot of
people you know his sister had passed
away a few years ago from scleroderma
which is a skin
disease and he raised tons and tons of
money for that he was always helping
people you know it's it's sort of cliche
when when anyone that we all know from
television
passes away especially so quickly we all
say these good things about him about
him or her but i i just know he was such
a great guy it's really
it's a sad day you know we live in these
polarized times how many people as i
said how many people kind of bring us
all together
these days we we need more of that for
sure and by the way bob you know he
didn't love all of the politics of fox
news but he would be very happy that you
guys are doing this tribute to him and
that you brought me on to talk about him
uh because again he wanted he wanted us
all to figure out a way through this
and he was on fox and friends a number
of times as you've seen the sound bite
montage earlier dave dave the thing
about uh bob saget is and you know this
um there's the
there's the tv version of america's dad
yeah which is so wholesome and
so
uh
you know just right down
the the middle of the road but then
there's
bob saget
who
he's got a mouth on him because he's
just playing for laughs and he knows
exactly how to do it and it is
hysterical
yeah well look i i know a ton of comics
and comics love to make people laugh but
i don't know any comic that loved to
make people laugh more than bob and when
you juxtaposed danny tanner as you said
this perfectly clean cut you know 80s
90s sitcom guy who who couldn't say
something mean and he was over the top
in in the cheesiness and all that and
when you juxtaposed that with the bob
saget the stand-up bob saget who loved
to work blue loved to work dirty his
book uh dirty daddy he he loved you know
the aristocrats joke that he was famous
for it's like those two things those
were both a piece of him you know it
wasn't just the guy who was hosting
america's funniest home videos to watch
people that would get hit with uh you
know a golf ball in the crotch he he
really just uh he was a full guy who he
could do danny tanner he could do the
dirty stuff and uh as we talked about on
my show maybe a year or so ago he wanted
to work to the end he said i'll be i'll
be 90 something and they'll put me on
stage and i'll just have a thing in my
ear and they can read me the lines but
he he loved what he did he loved what he
did
yeah dave uh he was in our living rooms
and our dens and our you know on tv
growing up throughout all of our lives
so we felt like he was america's dad
when you found out about the news i know
you were in a mexican restaurant tell us
what happened
yeah you know i was sitting at a mexican
restaurant i'm here in florida too i'm
i'm in the miami area bob obviously was
in orlando
bob loved tequila we we had a lot of
nights with a lot of tequila and i was
sitting at this tequila joint and
everybody i kid you not everybody was a
big bar probably about 30 people
everybody at the bar and then the
restaurant i started you know everyone's
phones were lighting up i heard all
these people talking about bob and uh i
just went up to this group next to us
about six people and we i said you know
i know bob i heard they were talking
about the aristocrats joke
and we all did some shots and everybody
just told stories and talking about full
house and talking about america's
funniest home videos and that's the
tribute that bob would have loved that
there was it wasn't just there i mean i
saw it all over all over online uh and i
just want to send some extra love to
bob's wife kelly who's who's just so
wonderful there she is in that picture
she just she's just a great gal and uh
you know i'll get back to la hopefully
to see her soon dave 15 seconds did he
complain about anything not feeling well
or anything like that
no
no i texted with him two or three days
ago as a matter of fact i'm sure you
guys saw that last instagram post he
looks like he looks like a million bucks
and he just did a stand-up show in
orlando and he was saying how he's ready
to be back
too i'm shocked guys
all right dave rubin joining us uh from
boca raton
uh thank you very much dave for
remembering your friend yeah i
appreciate it guys all right
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell